today's topic joe rogan made some
comments about video games i want to
take a quick look
who joe hogan thank you joe hogan you're
going to
make sure that's where once you drew
brazilian juice
hey my hair curtains your one and two i
found i don't know if you agree with
this
there's uh there were a ton of kids
along the way growing up as i was
building my business
that uh would say oh i'm not into this
i'm not into that
kind of like you described yourself and
they don't do anything
because they're looking for that thing
and i would argue
do something do [ __ ] something until
you find that thing
yeah i've never been that kid though i
know i've always been into things i was
when it was an
art or i was into something i was i
always found things that i was
interested in just none of them
seemed like they were normal things that
other people wanted to do for a living
like the path
like a career path but i think that
there's
a lot of people that don't have any
there's no one there
they're not modeling their life after
someone that they see that they admire
someone that's successful someone that
is doing something that they enjoy and
love
sometimes kids have to see that and if
their parents
are living a bullet life and their
neighbors live in a bulleted life and
most their family lives a bull
life they just lay around you know and
then they they seek refuge
or video games or something that
stimulates them and video games are a
real problem
their real problem you know why because
they're in fun
and you don't yeah well i have a real
problem with them
and you you you do them and they're real
exciting but you don't get anywhere
right
it's like you could do like like martial
arts right you could learn jiu jitsu
you get obsessed by jiu-jitsu and then
three years later
you're you're like an elite jiu-jitsu
athlete you're like you're entering in
competitions you're a purple belt
you're moving up yeah you're doing well
you're thinking like i might be able to
open my own school one day that
confidence yeah if i have a hundred
students
and those hundred students are paying me
x amount of dollars per month i can make
a living
holy [ __ ] i can have a this would be
amazing and then you see your jiu jitsu
school and your jiu jitsu instructor has
all these students and drives a mercedes
and he's got a nice family and like
that's the future this way you're doing
something exciting and fun
and you don't or you could just be
playing [ __ ] video games three years
later you could be that same kid
just playing video games waiting for the
next vix whatever the
game is you know next xbox game to come
out and you're going to waste your time
you you have children i have i have
children and
um it's a big battle in the house and
and my kids i don't know if you're
you're going through this but my kids
are now saying well dad this guy made
all this money with this video game that
he's saying that's real too so like
that's one in a billion kid i don't know
if it's one in a billion but
you know look i heard the same argument
about comedy
it's going there but what
the way he's talking about video game is
like a lot of immigrant parents talking
about either comedy or arts or or
singing and this and that
not a lot of people make it yes it's
hard yes it's really hard and
he's making an argument that you know
you could do jujitsu and be obsessed by
jujitsu and then after that you'll be
or you could do the jiu jitsu and just
do jiu jitsu because you want to do jiu
jitsu
you don't have to necessarily do a
career with that thing maybe you're
still going to be three years later down
the line
and you're still going to be at your jiu
jitsu class and you're thinking that
because
people do things for different reasons i
understand why you're saying that video
games
is a problem video games can be a
problem depending on
on a lot of factors right not everything
is on the same level
absolutely right like i'm not going to
compare
learning karate from a young age
to me playing metal gear solid
i understand right so do have i i i
hand coordination you do have different
skill sets i'm not saying it's the same
thing
or say but you can find the same things
in that you know yes uh
martial arts are based on you know
advancing well if you don't advance
in a game you don't go nowhere as well
it could be a goal it could set some
things for some people it could be a
problem depends how you manage it
and for some other people it can be
something that helps them coming from
that background here's why
slightly disagree the addictive nature
and the length of which you can do video
games
makes it very different from other
activities i can only do jujitsu in a
day
for oh so long i can only do
karate in a day because a physical body
will wear down eventually
you can't just be there for 12 hours
people can do
benders on video games where they go for
36 48
and the highly addictive nature and also
the ways video games are structured
especially nowadays is that
it's always meant to incentivize you
with a little win here yeah a little
wind there
get your dopamines going so that you
feel it but it doesn't necessarily mean
that it's a good
thing i'm not saying no it's like saying
gambling
like going to the casino could be the
same thing as jitsu yeah no
no because the way it's structured like
okay take take
fifa for example yeah fifa got these
packs that you can buy
right and they have this whole system
where you have to because it's
ea sports [ __ ] it's in the game
and in your pockets and in mine now oh
now you're broke
it's bad and so i think there is a bit
of that difference now again i'm also
saying this from the disciple where it's
like
video games can be just a formal
entertainment like a movie yeah that's
what you're saying you know
you spend two hours you enjoy a
beautiful experience you come back the
next day you do a bit of progression
i think most things in moderation
are great yeah most things in moderation
are great when it comes to video games a
lot of people are highly addictive and
spend
tremendous amounts of time on it when i
see someone playing video games and i'm
like you're very like
not doing anything i just questioned
myself is the video game really the
problem or that person has deeper issues
weird parallel i'm gonna do but bear
with me i have
i've noticed that a lot of our
colleagues
wendy when they stop abusing
whether whatever they do some other
thing as
intense whether it's sports or
eating or it's something something else
is replaced
so it was not so much the drug was
really the thing that was because it's
just
bad all over but
there's something in them that is addict
like
they have an addictive personality you
understand so when i see someone
with the video games again i'm not a
professional but i'm trying to look at
different perspective here
is it the video game or is it something
bigger than that the way he puts things
it's like video games are bad they're a
real problem
yeah there's people that have a video
game problem but it depends how you
treat it you know i mean
i'm not the ones to be like yeah video
games are a problem they're bad
and they're really this and that and
you're not going to accomplish anything
yeah
i would i would put like a little bit of
water in my wine here's what i diluted
i would never do a lot of people spend a
lot of time playing video games a lot of
people spend a lot of time watching just
random youtube videos
true okay and having been through
both of those cycles before where you're
spending hours and there's not really
much it's just constant
[ __ ] neurons firing and it just it's
just empty
like empty calories since it's the best
way i could see what you're saying
obviously it's not good to spend all
your time doing that whereas you could
be productive with something that's more
difficult maybe not as
instantly rewarding but definitely
builds your character i do think there
is something to that theory
and i actually have to quit video games
to be a more productive person
i couldn't do it in moderation because
the games were too addictive too good
the golden era of ps2 was too much for
me to handle
there was video games all the time and
so i had to
kind of distance myself from that in
order to feel better
and to feel more productive now people
there's a lot of people who can't handle
in moderation they come home from work
they play two hours of call of duty they
feel good that's their entertainment
that was their grey's anatomy yeah
two episodes they're good to go right
like everyone's got
if you can do it in moderation
everything is good but there's a lot of
people who don't know how to handle in
moderation
who do everything in excess so is it the
people that are a problem or the video
games itself because you replace the
video game with something else well
it's gonna be there well the addictive
personality is gonna be there
yes but also not everything is created
equal
some things are more addictive than
others casinos are built in a way to be
addictive
right the the sounds the bells the fact
that the free drinks they don't put no
clocks there's no windows
yes my you know my my own parents were
like do you know how few people make it
as a comedian i was like okay
does anybody make it somebody makes it
right they figure out how to do it they
make a living
i'm gonna do that just stop look i know
what i'm doing i was
real lucky that my parents were not
around very much so i didn't get much
advice
so i i figured it out myself so there
was no one telling me i couldn't do it
so greenfield yeah just i was like i'm
gonna find my way through this
and since no one's telling me it's
impossible no one's telling me i can't
occasionally i would hear someone say
what are the odds i'm like listen to
this
loser that's my thought was always like
that guy's a loser
like if you think like that you're a
loser but there are kids that make a lot
of [ __ ] money playing video games
but the thing is like you have to be
adaptable you have to be able to play
multiple video games because
the one video game that you get really
good at what are the odds that's going
to be around five years from now
you know like what's the big one now
like fortnight is that did they make
money off of that
yeah yeah and then there's a call of
duty
they make money off that what's the big
money starcraft used to be the big one
right
[ __ ] that's the old ass reference the
log out this old ass
starcraft man
no but i'm mad at him because he laid
off he laid off the video
you know what his call to fame is quick
[ __ ] that's old
league of legends counter-strike
counter-strike is a it's still the
half-life mod yeah
uh variations of it have come out but
it's still basically the same exact game
they don't make money off quick though
right not really not really but i tell
you what i tell you he always brings up
do they do they make money off uh mario
brothers
do they make money off of that in the in
the
in the world do they make money off
doctor mario do they make money off of
that god did they make money off galaga
i might as well just bring them out all
but it's okay i get it
your oldest i wouldn't say that it's
absolute in an absolute
and it's you know yeah all video games
are bad and this that
then again i don't think he exactly said
that and he put
at the end like i was able to be like
yeah you know what you put it in
in better words than i ever would so i
understand what you i understand what
he's saying
yeah you know what it is it's just
balance
balance balance especially as a young
person ideally you want to be trying a
couple things you want to
be doing different stuff i'm not saying
deny young people the access to video
games not at all
i'm saying give them a wealth of
experience but it'll help define them as
a person yeah and it'll help them grow
you know that's that's the only thing
but listen i got friends who stream for
a living they make millions of
and i'm happy for them and that's why i
wouldn't say that you can't make money
for video games or you should stop
no okay i'm not saying that but i'm
saying is that
there is nothing healthy about playing
video games for eight to ten hours even
for my streamer friends
all right don't tell me there's a cost
to it and if they weren't making money
they definitely wouldn't do it okay
so all i'm trying to say is find a good
balance because it can have a really bad
pull on you
and i think especially for young minds a
wealth of experience is always the best
thing
you know before coming to this if i
didn't do all the other stuff that i did
i probably wouldn't be the person i am
today doing the content the way i'm
doing it now
i think people went at joe a little bit
hard for these comments but i think when
you take it in the greater context i see
what you're saying he's just saying
that could be a problem it can be a
problem and it can be highly addictive
and you know what some gaming companies
have actually been sued
by governments for making their stuff
too addictive and making it
like i love video games they were a huge
part of my childhood and
my personal development so i'm not
[ __ ] on it at all if you play video
games keep playing enjoy
just always remember moderation is key
don't get comfortable
spending your whole day on video games
because it's noise
all right you know what i'm talking
about if you play video games sometimes
it's just noise you're not even having
fun
but you're so used to just a you can't
stop
if that's what's going on take a couple
steps back i got cycles
in the winter yeah i'm gonna play video
games
i'm gonna be but then yeah yeah i'm
gonna try to enjoy
myself in my life but i get it i get it
i get what joe was saying
well these are our thoughts on video
games and being too addictive but we
want to hear your opinions let us know
what you guys think in the comments
[Music]
below
foreign